all right John John where'd you grow up
where are you from originally um I'm
originally from Massachusetts
Springfield Massachusetts tell me about
your family two older brothers and an
older sister I'm the youngest U mom is
was divorced uh raised with with my
stepdad and my and my mom uh moved out
to
California in
72 and um that's when they had that big
earthquake and stuff and so I guess my
mom told me that I had night tears or
something and they Shi me back to
Massachusetts living my grandmother
until I was 10 cuz you so scared of the
earthquakes yeah I guess so I don't know
I mean night ter I you know I was so
young and then moved back to
California and by that time I was into
sports you know baseball baseball was my
thing I lived and breathed it and um and
where I lived it was a bunch of Kids on
the Block and stuff and you know you how
you always get in fights with the kids
and stuff and I was I was a smart ass
you know I always got into fights with
with other kids and stuff cuz stupid
I would say to them and uh then I
got uh then when I turned 15 I went to
uh uh to the high school Al Hamra High I
was living out in Montery Park and
Alhambra at the time and I got
introduced to smoking weed you know and
then right soon right after that then it
was a free
Basin and I was like 15 at the time and
I thought it was the greatest thing ever
you know and that kind of pretty much
put a cap on my baseball career cuz I
want to party you know I want to hang
out with the girls and you know and back
then we had cholos and you know gangs
and stuff like that and I got jumped
into a gang out there um and I was a
cholo for few years until up until I got
married I was married I got married when
I was
19 and had twin boys a couple years
later and uh I was still doing still
doing drugs I was U drinking drinking
then and uh it was I was a heavy drinker
for a while I would black out and
sometimes I end up in my neighbor's
living room in the middle of his floor
in the middle of the day I don't know
how I got into his house but I've done
that a few times and uh you know I
thought it was funny at first but uh you
know as I got older I was like God how
stupid that was you know how bad I was I
was such a bad Drinker and uh then I
started getting into Coke the 80s came
around got into Coke and oh massive
amounts of coke I worked for a Shell gas
station at the time and I would steal
all their motor oil to pay for my Coke
and stuff and uh and then uh my wife was
doing coke but not as much as me but I
still kept going and I ended up uh going
from Coke to crack started cooking it
myself was trying to raise kids trying
to work and stuff ended up selling their
jewelry everything for the crack and I
did that for about 2 years and thank God
I'm glad I'm not doing that anymore cuz
that was just just a horrible two years
of my life doing that it was bad I
used to
drive to Matha park right there on third
in bonnieb and pick up uh you know some
cracks some plates and I jump on the two
freeway I was living in Glendale and I
would hot boox myself in my truck and
that's all I would do is just drive up
and down the two freeway getting high in
my truck you know and uh and then I had
to go home and then go watch the kids
and stuff and I'd be just gacked out you
know it was pretty bad and I stayed
skinny for years years years and then um
I don't know it just one day I just I
think I had enough and I stopped doing
everything for about 5 months started
working out I put it like I got up to
about 180 lbs you got clean yeah I got
clean for about 5 months you know it was
about as longest I ever went clean and
then I went back to drinking but I still
kept on the weight you know I wasn't
doing any uh Coke at the time and then I
got introduced to uh to meth somebody
was smoking it out of a glass pipe and I
was like what the hell you guys doing
crack and they're all no this is meth
meth and I went oh let me try and I
started doing that and I've been doing
that God I don't know for a long time 30
years at least 3 35 years do you prefer
meth to crack uh oh yeah hell yeah
they're both up hell yeah because I
wasn't I felt like I needed to be in
control of my high you know I was I
always say I'm not I'm an user I'm not
an abuser of it but crack I was an
abuser of it you know to the point where
I was you know going to motels and stuff
and just just to get high in the motels
and that's all i' be doing is have my
ear up against the wall and listening to
other people thinking if they're coming
to get me and stuff or I'll see people
like outside my window like they they
looked like they were smoking a
cigarette in the bushes and stuff that's
on crack you're descri yeah that was
onra that's behavior that I I hear from
people that smoke meth yeah oh meth meth
I wasn't I'm I don't really hallucinate
too much on meth um I may get super
gacked you know on it and and I I might
hear things but I just roll at the
punches you know I just roll with you
know if somebody's coming to get me
that's how I see it you know then
they're going to come drug affect
everyone differently yeah it's yeah it
does and you know I guess I can consider
myself a functioning addict I still do
it I buy half ounces every two weeks you
know and that's just for me personally
of meth yeah you know like like the
other day I just bought a half ounce you
know and uh and I share you know I share
it you know with some people that need
it and stuff and you know I've had
girlfriends that that done meth I have
girlfriends done heroin my last
girlfriend was Big Time heroin addict
and she used to shoot up full like 80
milligrams of it and just like and it
was dark and you know it was bad you
know and she would she died a couple
times and you know I caught her on one
of her ODS and stuff lucky I did and and
the whole time she's oding on me I'm
just thinking about what her mom's going
to say you know and she was a lot
younger you know half my age I was think
I was like 52 at the time and she was
26 and uh you know we ended up uh
breaking up it was a bad breakup too I
ended up getting shot by her new
boyfriend at the time when I when we had
do when we did our breakup and stuff I
guess he wanted to be part of her life
or you know I guess he wanted to be her
hero so I ended up getting shot twice by
him and he shot at me three times but
twice I I got hit with a bullet you know
but I I survived that and you know I
just I don't know just been getting high
every day what is it that makes you want
to do that it high is there something
from your childood that you running away
from or my child no I mean you know I
had I don't know if it's basic I mean
I've been I've been I've had a sexual
predator one time I tried to get me when
I was like 10 years old really yeah he
wrote a motorcycle it's it's I don't
know whether I blocked it out and stuff
but I would sneak out of my house to go
meet him at the corner on my street did
something happen uh I don't think so I
don't remember if anything happened but
U my mom ended up finding out that
that's what I was doing and they had the
police come and they took an interview
for me but I can't remember what the
guy's name was now or or anything like
that but it was kind of you know it was
it was it seemed like I was okay what I
was doing you know he made it seem like
I was okay for me to him to take a
couple pictures you know I never was in
a a room alone with them we were mostly
outside and stuff and and I didn't
realize what he was until as I got older
you know that this was somebody that was
bad then I've been kidnapped when I was
15 uh by some girl's uh mom's boyfriend
he thought I was doing something with
with her daughter or something like that
and he ended up grabbing me and throwing
me in the back of his back of his car or
back seat of his car and I had to he
made me stay down and he says you know
what he goes you're not going to go home
you better better pray for your mom that
she doesn't kill herself cuz you're
going to die today and I was just like
you know I was 15 you know and I was I
was a cholo at the time too and you know
tough as I can be
and uh I ended up you know getting away
you know I ended up bolting out the the
back door I don't know he left it
unlocked or he did it on purpose or
maybe he was with me I don't
know but anyway he ended up going to
jail that guy for kidnapping and uh and
then but I I still kept partying I mean
I didn't I didn't see anything wrong
with it you know what I was doing it was
like the normal thing back then
everybody was getting you know coked out
or stoned or drinking are there
alcoholics or yeah in your family uh
yeah my stepdad was an alcoholic
couldn't stand him he was the worst
alcoholic ever he was just a mean
he was like 4 fo 10 he was a
professional racehorse jockey and my mom
worked all the time she ended up only a
couple T restaurants and but even then
man I was drinking big time too you know
in school I go to school drunk or leave
for lunch and go to my friend's house
and get drunk there go buy you know
bottles of bardi and stuff and just
pound one of those or or
or Johnny Walker or Jack Daniels we go
to football games and I would steal
purses from the underneath the bleachers
you know so we can get money and stuff
you know um I wasn't big into stealing
I'm a horrible thief and but you know I
would do it sometimes you know just to
get what I needed um you know I guess it
kind of carried on to my adulthood um I
started stealing got a little bit bigger
a little bit you know crazier you know
had I was carrying a gun with me all the
time um I was stealing cars left and
right you know and uh and this is uh
this is while I was married at the time
still and I got married when 19 got
divorced when I was 37 so after after 37
then that's when it really started a lot
of crazy started happening because
I had nobody to monitor my drug habit
cuz I was just a weekend partyer what I
would drink during the week and stuff I
would fuse like oranges with the with
vodka you know and sugar and just mix it
up so it tastes like orange juice and
smelled like orange juice and I just
used to drink that all the time every
day and I'd be at work and I used to
work for a one of those Warehouse
companies you know Costco and I I made
it up to a a junior manager making
pretty good money too like a 62,000 a
year and that was like in 1998 and you
were using I was using every day every
day I get up and that's the first thing
I would do smoke a bowl or snort a line
you know whatever got me going and then
take my Sunny D's that I used as
thinking you know they were my orange
shoes and stuff and I go to work and I
work I work every day you're a
functional addict I was functioning yeah
I wasun how many years did you do that
oh God I mean until till Rec I mean till
now I mean I did 13 years with that
company and there was math you were
using I was doing math yeah at the time
and I was drinking too you know and
marijuana used to be a big thing for me
I used to just crave that all the time
but then that just got I stopped doing
uh opinion on functional drug addicts uh
somebody who can get up and go to work
every day but you think it's possible
yeah it is it's it's very possible I I
do it I do it every day I still do it to
this day I mean I now I I don't I don't
rush myself I'm late every day but uh
I'm there though I'm there to work and I
used to have a rule that I don't get
high at work cuz I didn't want to be
embarrassed of getting caught and that's
my thing I don't want anybody to know
that I get high so I function as a
normal person throughout the day
and stopping is not an option uh if
somebody gave me a reason to if if there
was somebody out there that gave me a
reason not to do it anymore then I
probably would I mean I'm 56 going on 57
you know I'm going to be an addict until
I'm until I die maybe I don't want to
quit I don't want to quit what does
crystal meth do for you at this point it
coms me down bals you down yeah it makes
me even kill you know makes me uh uh
more tolerable to people and I think
people are
stupid you know if if I'm not on it I'm
I'm an the real me comes out and
I'm an and I'll tell you to and
I'm pretty honest I'm pretty pretty
straightforward probably one of the most
straightforward people that most people
will meet you know and I tell you what's
on my mind at the time no matter who you
are have you smoked this morning yeah I
smoked probably about 10 minutes before
I got here too I so I mean it's just
something that I do I lost most majority
of all my teeth you know and I and
adventur yeah both of them and I got you
know I got lucky somebody told me about
you know cuz I did have a half partial
cuz I only had half of my teeth up on
top and my partial broke my motor's
nightmare ever and I broke those and now
I just had this snaggle tooth and then
no teeth just on this one complete side
and uh and I had that for did that for a
few years and then I was like you know I
can't eat couldn't eat then my other
teeth started breaking and I said I got
to get something done and somebody
introduced me to some uh some somebody
was doing something on the Internet for
uh Dental Grants you know they can give
you some implant Grant and I knew it was
a kind of like a you know marketing
thing you know you go in there and they
they tell you that they'll drop the
price off but they're really not doing
that they're just you know getting you
in there and giving you the price that
they normally would and that's fine with
me because I'm not going to pay that
bill you know and and so you know I just
put down a little deposit and then the
rest of this history you know I got
teeth and now I can I'm still learning
how to smile and I've had these probably
about 3 years now and uh yeah it's it's
you know it's hard for me to to show my
teeth or something I'll just still keep
my mouth shut you know and they say hey
you got nice teeth and I'm oh yeah then
I'll show my teeth but uh you know I
deal with like stress and everything
with jokes you know people say I'm real
funny I should do
standup and so I just like you know all
I do is just make fun of other people
you know and they think it's it's funny
but I make fun of myself more than
anything else you know you know if
people are uncomfortable with the with
with gay gay people I I make it I make
them think that I was I'm gay as well
you know just so that you know just so
they they see that oh there's somebody
like you know I consider myself not a
tough guy but I'm not afraid you know
I'm not afraid of anything um except
getting caught that's the only thing I'm
afraid of is getting caught and being
exposed that I'm a drug addict
you know what's your biggest
regret uh that I that I walked away from
a career that could have you know made
my life a little more
easier you know it was
um it was it was it at the time it felt
easy to do it felt smart that I was
doing the right thing I was walking away
from a career and I didn't want that
company to know that I was an addict
that I was addicted to alcohol and and
meth at the time cuz when I got divorced
it just went South you know nobody had
to monitor me which was great could you
have been functional on
crack no no I was not functional on
cocaine you could cocaine I cocaine yeah
I could I can I can be up all night long
all night long and then if I had to go
to work I just I go out and get a or I
would have a bottle of Nyquil and I
would down a bottle of that just so I
can get some sleep you know and I sleep
my two hours and then I get up and
what's your what's your sleep schedule
like
now God you probably almost consider me
a somniac it's very little sleep I'll
probably nod sometimes you know if
something's boring you know I'll nod
real quick but I can hear what's going
on and then I'll just wake up but if I
get like two hours in I'm refreshed like
today like today I got a couple hours
you go some nights with no sleep yeah
I'll go days days without it and still
be functioning still going to work I
have a guy that I work for who does
construction and stuff and he picks me
up and everything I lolly gag you know I
take my time as I get ready to go and I
said no I'm not ready yet I got to take
my dog for his walk first hold on you
know and I and I have a great dog and uh
and then I then I'm ready you know and
he knows that I do meth and stuff and
he's sober and he's religious and stuff
and he's always telling me why you got
to be doing that why you got to be
doing that I said so I'm not an
to you that's why so that way
you don't get a prick coming working for
you because that's what you'll get you
know you get somebody that's straight
out and I'll look at every flaw that you
have and I'll point it out to you you
know just because I can because I don't
give a you know I feel that I'm at
the age I don't give a I don't give a
and you know people come with
me with their problems because they
believe that I'm intelligent and I give
them sound advice okay yeah maybe so but
I really don't give a I don't give
a what's going on with you or you
or you or you I don't care what
anybody's doing I don't care what
anybody says I don't care what your
problem is if something's sad I I don't
want to hear it you know these are
shoulders not to cry on if you want to
cry go to the bathroom and cry in there
do you have kids I have twin boys yeah
they're men now they're in their 30s
yeah you raised them yeah up until I was
for they were 14 then I got divorced and
then uh I had a house you know had
couple cars couple dogs swimming pool
you know I was living the dream you know
I bought my first house when I was
32 and uh and ended up having to sell it
you know after the divorce I wish we
didn't have to do that California sucks
you know you got to split all your your
your assets and stuff but uh you know my
wife around on me with my best
friend and that that really set me off I
mean you know she was she was going to
die she was going to die the that day
that I found out and I had set it up for
her where U she had sent some email to
my best friend at the time and something
about how he misses Mish hearing his
voice and some other and I made
a whole bunch of copies of it it was an
email cuz of our house uh computer at
the time you know back then you know
computers were still fairly new and and
I would use her email to play u NFL
games you know bet on games and so I saw
the email draft so I hit you know opened
it up and it was to my best friend like
8 days after my birthday and her
apologizing for the Friday which was my
birthday that she couldn't hang out with
me on that or hang out with him on that
day so I made a whole bunch of copies
after you know how that feel uh it feels
it still drains me you know like I feel
the blood drained from my head you know
down my shoulders all the way to my
hands you know that's where it stops the
blood and I just feel empty inside you
know and I was planning on being married
to this woman until we were old you know
I got married when I was 19 got divorced
when I was 37 that's a pretty long time
you know raised kids you know we we both
had careers um you know I had money in
my pocket all the time it was you know
it was a good time in my life
and then that just that one moment you
know and just kind of just I just pissed
it all the way after that you know she I
told her there was emergency at home I
said come home and uh and so she came
home and and she peaked in like you know
to see what was up and I said come on in
lock the door and I was going to set her
up to where I had the copies of uh her
draft that she was sending to my friend
and I was just going to throw them at
her and they were just going to fall to
the floor and she as she went to go bend
down I was going to come her on the
couch with my bat and then I wanted to I
was going to smack her right on top of
her head and just split her head open
just that and I had no no remorse or
nothing I just knew that that's what I
was going to do and I didn't care about
whether my kids were going to be without
parents or anything like that I just
knew that that she up she did
something that that she shouldn't have
done you know and is that what happened
no lucky I'm a science kind of person
and so when I threw the paper and they
all went to the floor except this one
and this one just floated up to her
chest and she grabbed it like that and
by that time I was already coming around
the couch with the bat and she saw me
and she ran around the kitchen table and
I told her I said today you're going to
die I said what is that and so you know
we started she started to explain
herself you know about what what she was
sending and stuff and it was all
you know it was all
and I told her I said today you're going
to die and and your kids are going to be
without parents because I'm I'm not
running I'm not going anywhere I'm going
to you know stay here you know until the
police come and arrest me because uh you
know uh there's nothing left for me here
and I was and that's when I started
getting I started I drank a lot that day
after I found out and then uh so she so
I she convinced me that you know that it
was really nothing it was really nothing
and and I said well I said I'll I'll be
back and I went to leave and I was going
to go to his house and I was going to
kill him and I saw her jump on her phone
and I stopped and my truck and I backed
it up I came back to the house and I I
knew she was going to call him cuz he
had he had guns and stuff and
so I let I let her stay there I let her
stay at the house and I I went to move
out and uh and then when I C I came back
like about a week later and I told her
that she needed to move out you know
that it's not right that she has a place
to live you know I can raise the kids
myself and I was still working at the I
was on vacation at that time and so I
had little free time on my hands and uh
and I gave her a suitcase about this big
and I said whatever you can stuff in
there you can take with you I said so
get the stuff in and I said and I don't
want you to talk talking to my best
friend again she said she told me no I'm
not going to
stop and I and then by that time I was
just like this I said so that's
when I started I really started drinking
and I just wanted to to just Escape you
know what was happening cuz it didn't
seem real married almost 20 years yeah
18 years 18 years and uh you know we we
still talk you know we talk once in a
while I still see my boys you know I
still see these 14y olds they're they're
in their 30s and I see 14-year-old boys
you know you are you still angry with
her uh no no I I forgave her long time
ago and it took her 4 years to apologize
to me though you know and she goes we're
all human yeah she goes if there's
anything I can do you know to help you
through this and I said yeah there's one
thing you can do I said you can go
through what I went through I want you
to feel what I
felt you know cuz um cuz it was
I mean I I I hated people I hated people
that were happy and and and being
couples and stuff I was I became an
angry angry man and then I started to
become violent once I was you know once
we were already divorced and separated
and stuff and and anybody that said
anything stupid to me I was was on them
and by that time you know like I said I
I picked up a little bit of weight and I
put some muscles on and I was Affiliated
to to a gang and and so anytime I had
any trouble I would call call the homies
and they we would come and we would take
whatever we wanted I used to run around
with a Barber's razor and hold it to
people's
scalps just to collect money for
something make a easly $300 you know on
like A1 th000 th000 debt or I just start
taking all their stuffff whatever I
thought was worth money you know and
never got in trouble for it you know I F
you know people fear people that are
serious and I my eyes were dead too
that's why I still cover my eyes you
know because I I know what that guy
looks like you know with those dead eyes
and it was I was dead and I didn't care
either back then either and uh so I got
a bad reputation people wouldn't allow
me in their homes they were my friends I
would have to make a phone call to get
in
and and so I just started doing you know
more and more meth God how much meth I
used to do I used to buy I used to buy
pounds of it for a friend and he would
give me a pound so it would be like 5
pounds at a time he give me one pound
out of the five I can keep it and sell
it man I was snorting it I was shooting
it I was smoking it whatever whatever to
get that high that I wanted and uh and
then uh one day and then were the
differences between smoking shooting and
yeah there's big differences in all
three you know it all depends you know
you can get you can get some method that
is good for smoking you can also do a
turkey baster I've heard I can do turkey
baster I've done that I've done that
I've had you know I've had girlfriends
that are you know I have many many
girlfriends after I got divorced and you
know and I like I like them all I like
them all no matter what they are being
you know big girls you know skinny girls
you know Mexican black you know right
now I'm into black
girls you know there's a couple black
girls that are that hang out that I that
I know that I like you know we fooled
around you know I fool around God I've
been with so many women it's unreal from
37 into my age now does crystal meth
help with that um yeah it does actually
I've heard that actually it does it it
it does help me but you know I'm 56
years old so I need a pill on an
occasion you know other than that I need
something for you to to beat that
desensi you know being desensitized you
know you know watch a lot of porn you
know do a lot of jacking off you know uh
and but I get I find the sexy girls and
that's what turns me on is girls that
are sexy that do things weird My First
Girlfriend after I got divorced she was
bisexual and I call her my teacher and
she pretty much taught me a lot of
things and she like to strap one on on
occasion and you know she wanted me to
some guy and I was like no I don't
want to be no guy I'll let him
suck my dick for you but you know that's
about it I don't want to be no
guy I don't want no hairy or
anything like that I said but you can
me if you want and so she thought
that was great so I used to let her
me on you know once in a while and stuff
and that was fun you know it was fun cuz
she was an aphrodesiac this girl I mean
anywhere we went people were just drawn
to her and we would have you know three
SS and five SS you know like little
Carousel of of people you know that I
don't even know or she barely even knew
would that be happening if you guys
weren't on meth uh probably not probably
not you know but uh it was it was you
know I had some good times and but you
know like those those relationships all
my Rel relationships that were with
drugs it was they were all they all
ended you know maybe not all bad but
they ended you know we just kind of
moved on and did something or something
my last girlfriend she was a lot younger
I mean you know but she was just a
horrible girlfriend she's just was just
horrible for me and everybody kept
saying that but you know she was a good
you know and that's all I saw you
know that she was a good even
though she was doing heroin heroin which
I hated because I had friends that did
heroin and I had friends die from it
from fent and all I had them die from it
and you know and I didn't want somebody
dying in my care you know I I was I felt
that I had a
certain uh
uh certain level of of respect that I
that I believe that I had from people
they you know they trusted me and stuff
because I'm like I said I'm pretty
honest and you know I nowadays I don't
steal from anybody I don't take their
stuff and you know if I find a wallet on
the floor nowadays even if it had money
in it you know I I give that person a
chance you know and I'll either mail it
to them if I don't mail it to them then
I'll try to find something that I can
call them with you know if they have
like a doctor's card or something I let
them know that I found their wallet or
something just give them that
opportunity before I have to take it but
I've done some real crime stuff man real
crime stuff you know and done home
invasions and and you're living on the
streets now yeah I lived in I lived in a
goes hand in hand yeah I went from I was
living living with a friend before I
went super homeless um I was living with
a friend for about 3 years and then they
moved to Palmdale and a friend of mine
dropped off he had a pop out trailer and
it was a joke it was a joke he goes oh I
heard you going homeless so I brought
you this pop out trailer you know for
you to live in and you know I made fun
of it and everything and I was going to
fix it up and sell it you know and make
some money off of it but no I ended up
living in it and I lived in that thing
for about a year and a half and then I
went from that to a a to a motor home
and then from a motor home to another
motor home and then I finally I got some
Ed when Ed was happening everybody was
doing that unemployment I got some money
in and I bought another motor home which
I ended up giving it to my last
girlfriend which was a mistake you know
um and then uh I just and then from
there I went from this last motor home
that I was in to living in like a tent I
guess or fixed you know housing with the
with pallets you know and uh it's cold
and rainy at times man and it's pretty
bad I mean this this year is probably
one of the worst years I think for being
out on the streets you know with the
rain and everything the non-stop rain
and stuff and you know you can't get
warm enough you know and I got a dog too
and I hate that that my dog's being put
through what I've been put through so
you know the housing came and you know
they say we'll get you in a home and you
know and all I really care about is my
dog then you know he's he gets a better
life you know or lives better but he's
so loyal and and you know he knows
what's up with me and you know when it's
cold days and stuff he just gets right
up in my face and I got a bull mive uh
American Bulldog and he's a runt and I
got that uh and somebody was walking
down the street with them wanted a good
home for him and uh and I said yeah I'll
give him a good home I'll give him a
good home and I told my girlfriend I
said here this is you know your birthday
gift cuz we were talked about getting an
animal and but she never took care of it
she's horrible like I said a horrible
girlfriend at the time and so I ended up
with the dog and he's just been around
me ever since 5 years know he's been out
on the streets and he's very you know
he's friendly but he's but he's
protective and stuff and he you know
everybody loves him everybody loves him
he runs he runs the park you know pretty
much the park that I'm at and and all
the people they always come and say hi
to him first before they say hi to me
and stuff how does it feel to be 57
years old and living in a park yeah yeah
does that
feel well I feel embarrassed you know
and I've seen friends that I know that
that you know that I worked for or work
for me and they see me now on the street
and stuff and I could see that that that
sadness or that you know they you know
that patheticness like they you know
they think I'm pathetic or something I
don't know what that look is that it's
that look you know that makes me hate
where I'm at you know that I think that
I should should be doing something
better but but like I said I'm 56
there's not a lot of opportunity out
there for me anymore no no matter how
talented I am at what I do because for
me to go in and and and talk to somebody
about getting a job it's a difficult
thing and like I say I'm late to
everything I'm late to everything I mean
I had a dishwashing job for four years
and every day I was late every day no
joke for four years before they finally
fired me they ended up having to get a
new manager in into the restaurant that
was that and that person fired me
because I was late but I was late every
day no joke every day 10 minutes to a
half hour and I lived a block away and
then I go home for lunch and I get high
at lunch and then I come back to work
and I'm like 10 20 minutes late for that
you're a dysfunctional addict yeah so I
started becoming dysfunctional but you
know my work was really good I mean you
know how hard is it to be a dishwasher
well I don't know how hard it is I mean
I'm a Virgo everything is meticulous in
details being high everything is super
meticulous this in detailed and
everything takes a little bit longer but
I was quick at what I did I found found
a way to make it work for me you know
get in get out get in get out you know
make sure everything looked clean when I
left so I looked like a superstar so
they accepted me for being late I had
one you know I was missing teeth and
stuff you know and I I wouldn't talk to
nobody I hated having conversations you
know especially when I was looking for
work you know I I couldn't go in there
and just talk to somebody knowing that
they're looking at my mouth you know so
I would grow my mustache a little bit
longer so they couldn't see my teeth or
I to my head down and talk or I have my
hat I'm covering my eyes you know so
they wouldn't see you know I'm not I'm
not super intelligent but I'm
intelligent human being but there's a
lot of intelligent human beings out
there at the park and stuff I mean it's
just amazing how smart some of these
people are that are in these situations
you know they're doing their drug you
know doing drugs that are just pretty
much dominate their life it's number one
in their life you know I'm not going to
say that meth is my number one thing for
me but uh you know it's something I I
have a ritual doing you know on the
regular waking up and going to sleep
with it you know what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life oh God is there a lesson in
this I don't know if there's a lesson I
mean you know uh I I made a lot of
mistakes you know I made a lot of bad
choices and and I just got to make
better choices I don't use I don't use
meth as an excuse why I'm am where I am
CU I'm functioning I'm able to function
I'm able to do the things that need to
get done to make the money and I do and
I'll hustle and I'll make money and then
it'll pay for my habits and if it's
something like $100 just for a day just
for for doing a little bit of work yeah
that's enough for me I buy my buy my
half I have a little bit money I got gr
I got food stamps you know all I got to
do now is just get a roof over my head a
solid roof you know and that's something
that's coming from what I hear you know
they I I've talked to the people at tiny
homes and they uh they said that they're
doing intakes next week and that that uh
somebody from housing should set me up
for an appointment so I'll know for sure
whether I get in or not then if I'm in
there maybe things will change maybe
it'll be different you know that I have
a roof over my head that I got a safe
place for my dog you know and he's
everything to me too you know and I I
don't really want to talk about him
because it makes me sad but you know it
sucks it sucks for him you know he's a
good
dog all right all right John thank you
so much for sharing your story thank you
I wish you the best of
luck